in Mexico this morning a major city is
under lockdown after Security Forces
arrested the son of the drug kingpin
Joaquin El Chapo Guzman yesterday the
arrest led to an explosion of violence
in culiacan at least seven members of
the security forces were killed the
alleged drug cartel leader is now in
custody in Mexico City as Errol Barnett
reports this is not the first time the
younger Guzman has been arrested
the arrest of ovideo Guzman triggered a
violent response in culiacan Mexico home
base to the Sinaloa drug cartel armed
groups torch cars buses and trucks the
son of the notorious drug lord Joaquin
El Chapo Guzman was captured in a dawn
raid in the city after months of
surveillance
Mexico's defense secretary says security
stopped a vehicle carrying the suspected
drug trafficker once they nabbed Guzman
he says they came under heavy fire and
despite the barriers set up around kulia
Khan the Air Force was able to fly
Guzman to Mexico City
however the airport in kulia Khan came
under heavy fire during the operation
gunmen shooting at this Air Force plane
on the runway bullets hitting this Aero
Mexico flight while on the tarmac
sending passengers to take cover no one
was injured Thursday's arrest marks a
dramatic turn from the last time Guzman
was apprehended in the same city back in
2019 then after the titanium Guzman's
security and cartel members engaged in a
lethal day of violence only for
authorities to later release him Guzman
now faces charges in the U.S where his
father is serving a life sentence and a
Maximum Security federal prison in
Colorado it is not yet clear if
prosecutors have requested extradition
for the younger Guzman CBS mornings I'm
Errol Barnett